hey everybody my name is jasmine i'm
with get cake delay i'm a professional
pancake artist and i've been doing this
for about three years now we can do
faces we can do food if you name it we
can create it i've been challenged to
make pancake art today but blindfolded
i'm a little bit nervous but confident
that i can get the job done i have three
tries to recreate my favorite piece as a
pancake and at the end of all of this
three judges are gonna come in and see
if they can tell exactly what this
pancake is before i make a full out of
myself let me show you how it's really
done i'm gonna be making a taco pancake
but the way it's supposed to look
so first thing i'll do is i will start
by drawing the eyes on this cute little
taco let's give them a cute little shell
i'm gonna get some meat on the inside
and i'm gonna draw some cheese
afterwards i'm gonna take my white and
i'm gonna draw the eyes and we're gonna
give it some cute cheeks and then i'll
go ahead and fill in the black around
the eyes now i'm going to fill in the
inside outline that i did first add some
of the taco meat and i'm going to leave
some space in between so i can add some
latuga with a blindfold i think it's
going to be really hard to try and keep
up with all these small details i mean
where am i going to put the lettuce at
if i can't see where the lettuce is
supposed to go and now that i'm done i'm
going to add this outline just to make
sure that everything comes up together
and if i'm being honest the hardest part
about pancake art is waiting for it to
cook
right now i'm loosening up the edges
just so i can make sure that this taco
pancake is ready to flip
this looks ready it's taco time
on the count of three
one
two three
and that's a taco pancake
why you gotta be so
cute one of the things i'm worried about
is i have no idea if the taco meat is
gonna be in the right place or if i'm
gonna end up with a burnt taco at the
end of this i've got my bottle set up
i've got my griddle turned on and just
as a warning to everybody i am a
professional pancake artist and i do
have help on standby just to make sure
that i'm doing this safely please do not
try this at home now with that being
said let's get started
now this is where the scary part happens
i cannot see a thing right now all i
know is that my colors are supposed to
be in order and let me see where the
towel is at all right here goes the
middle i'm gonna get started with
drawing the eyes right now and i hope
that i'm drawing a circle it feels like
it
and i think the mouth goes right here
but it's kind of hard to tell
and i'm gonna give the taco an outline
just like i did in the beginning
but now that i've just lifted up my hand
i have no idea where i'm going
so i'm gonna draw the taco meat where i
think the taco meat might go don't judge
me and remember the cool thing about
pancake art is that there's no
real definition of art you're supposed
to just have fun with it
i feel like that's enough
oh look at those cute eyes
this one should hopefully be the taco
shell color i don't know where the taco
shell is at but i'm gonna just do this
because i know the shape of a taco shell
so at this point usually what happens is
after the outline is done i'm just gonna
fill in this taco right here and i bet
it's looking like the best taco you have
ever seen on tv maybe some taco meat
red orange
no red
yellow this is yellow so we're gonna
throw some cheese in there at least i
think this is yellow art is up to your
own interpretation and right now in my
eyes this is a beautiful taco
i hope that this is white
because i think that this is where the
taco is at i'm gonna do my best to give
it
a full outline oh i hit the edge so i'm
way off
but you know what i'm gonna trust my
instincts and i'm gonna turn this
griddle up
we're gonna wait for it to cook
so usually when i'm making a pancake i
can always tell that it's ready by
looking at the bubbles
this time i really can't see anything so
what i'm going to do is i'm going to
listen to see if it's done be careful
yeah i can oh i can feel like the heat
by the sounds of it i think it's ready
so i'm gonna take this spatula and i'm
gonna hopefully go under the edges of
this pancake very slowly all right on
the count of three
one two three
it's a taco
i thought i was squeezing out so much
more batter than i actually was we're
gonna try this a few more times to see
if i can get a little better by the time
the judges get here
i think i went wrong when i lost the
place where i started at so this time
what i'm gonna do is i'm gonna keep my
hand right here in the middle and hand
myself bottles with my left hand let's
get started i know my black is the first
one right here and i'm gonna start by
just keeping my hand right in the middle
and i'm not moving this baby this time
so i am going to draw my circles where i
feel
like this little taco smile would go and
i'm going to move my hand up slightly
just to give it a little bit more of a
round edge
so now i feel like i've at least done
the taco outline already and i'm gonna
keep
giving some more meat and some more
lettuce if i remember where i started my
wrist was on the bottom of the griddle
so i'm gonna try and get some eyes
right here
and right here and i think
that the cheeks go right here
and then i'm gonna try and fill this
taco in on the middle
some of this some of that and now i'm
gonna give him some taco meat
and i'm not gonna lift up my hand this
time i'm just gonna go straight around
because i know that the taco has an arch
at the top not too heavy on the tomatoes
am i right and some cheese now i'm
hoping that me anchoring my arm this
time even though i lifted it up is gonna
give me somewhat of an advantage for
this flip i didn't feel myself hit the
edge so i think i'm doing a little bit
better than the first time and i feel
like this hard strategy is gonna pay off
so this time just to be safe i'm
actually just gonna give it some
squigglies like this just so everything
hopefully comes up together i'm going to
turn up the griddle to 200 and now i
have to wait patiently for this pancake
to cook personally i think that attempt
number two is gonna be better than the
first one that i did as far as the
strategy goes and keeping my hand in the
same place i think that halfway through
i kind of lost all strategies and
started going with gut instinct again
and i can hear it crinkling
okay i feel like i might be breaking
some of the taco right now but as we all
know tacos are a little bit messy am i
right flip number two with the blindfold
on one two three
[Music]
it's a taco
that's not a taco but i still think it's
better than the first one that's a smile
give me one more try to get really great
at this oh my eyes
[Music]
this time with new technique i'm going
to keep my hand right in the middle and
i'm actually going to measure on each
side four fingers
that way i know that my wrist is
centered the entire time let's get
started
i'm going to start at the edge and
instead of lifting it up and making a
bunch of lines i'm going to make one
really long line so i'm going to give it
a bunch of squigglies because i think
that this taco shell is right here and
then i'm going to go back around just to
do some lettuce some extra squeeze i'm
going to put my wrist at the edge of the
towel and do another four count
[Music]
and i really hope this is helping
so those are my eyes
so i can fill in my circles
and i'm just gonna give it some cute
cheeks i'm gonna just fill this in as
much as i can
i think that's enough taco color so this
is my taco meat but this time i'm gonna
scoot up so i can give it somewhat of an
arch
and i'm gonna try and stay as small as i
can because i feel like i want to just
make it a little bit more confined and a
little bit more tighter if i can let's
throw some salsa inside of this taco
we're gonna add some cheese it's such a
weird habit to just
look down even though i can't see we're
gonna add some lettuce to the top of
that i don't want it to be a huge
pancake but i want it to be big enough
to eat all right so i'm gonna just take
some extra white and i'm gonna go around
the entire taco just to make sure
everything lifts up all at the same time
this is just my safety my safety border
doesn't that look like a tasty taco
and i'm gonna turn up the heat
this taco is its own expression of art
but it could look like a taco that's
been sitting in the fridge for a couple
days i feel like the eyes might be more
proportionate than the other ones
[Music]
and i know i look crazy doing this so i
think it's ready and i'm going to start
from the edge of the grill this time
push it down as hard as i can and i can
feel the edge
it's such a good feeling knowing that i
can feel where this pancake is at and
that i know that i'm actually getting
the edges up underneath it
sounds like it
just got to commit
one two three
[Music]
that's a taco
that is a blindfolded pancake art taco
by yours truly i'm thinking that the
third attempt is way better than all of
the attempts that i've done so far it
looks like a taco with a smiley face but
it also has some sour cream that may
have missed the shell but aside from
that i think it looks like a taco let's
get these judges down here and see what
they think of these blindfolded pancakes
hmm
this is like a rorschach so when it's
upside down it looks like a dog face
wait is this a car i think it looks like
a a dog car it kind of looks like a bus
that
maybe has i don't know like a tree vine
above it oh my god a pancake are you
sure this is a pancake i'm sorry if i
offended anyone it looks like half a
face
maybe this person was like blindfolded
while making this pancake
wow this is even harder this looks like
a taco
i think that's what that is you see but
now it looks like a happy face but the
smile looks like it has lettuce and
tomatoes in it this
looks like a pizza i think somebody was
trying to make a pizza because i can see
some toppings maybe some
pepperoni okay ice
mouth for sure 100
oh wait you know what hold up taking it
all back this looks like a taco
it's a smiling taco
this is definitely an anthropomorphic
taco
the tortilla there the contents of it on
the top the two eyes the smiley face the
the rosy cheeks this
looks like
a happy taco i feel like
the person who did this has made
pancakes before but maybe this is their
first time trying out the art was i
right is this a a taco with a face
i got it right it's a taco with a face
were they drunk they could have been
blindfolded they could have been hanging
upside down
yeah now now i really want to know what
the hell was going on
hey hi i know you
so this was the taco with the wow this
is actually my attempt at pancake art
blindfolded wow blindfolded you did an
amazing job well i've seen a lot of
tacos that look like this and they're
still delicious would you eat this yeah
i'd eat it i love pancakes too really
carbs hell yeah let's do it
give it to me girl yeah
after all three judges came by and
looked at my pancake art they were able
to guess that it was in fact a taco
pancake this was probably one of the
most challenging pancake car requests
that i've actually done in the history
of pancake art
moving forward i still believe that as
humans we can learn any skill in the
world including being blindfolded and
making pancake art i don't know how much
i'll be practicing this on my own but i
do know it's a skill i'll be adding to
my resume blindfolded or not as long as
you cover it in syrup it is always tasty
i'm gonna go eat one of these taco
pancakes see you guys later
next time the only thing that i would do
differently is not have a blindfold on
i'm just kidding i'll do it again
you